the babies are not the problem  the problem is the grown-ups we lack  compassion and sympathy and empathy for  others in their situation you're on a  plane and a baby's crying and you're  pissed off put your [ __ ] earpods in  Blast your [ __ ] Drake and shut your  [ __ ] mouth  or go ask the person if they need any  help  [ __ ] there's no dilemma with the babies  on airplanes The Dilemma is the lack of  Civility and kindness to strangers and  others that has been eliminated over the  last hundred years  [ __ ] loving our neighbors is long  [ __ ] gone how about we bring that  [ __ ] back there's no problem with  [ __ ] babies on planes there's  problems with lack of compassion let's  bring that [ __ ] back in 23. [ __ ]  Jesus  it's your [ __ ] song shut up